Let's illustrate how Panda's describe function works,
using our Laman baseball data set. Say
that our baseball data was loaded into
a Panda's data frame called baseball, using Panda's
read.csb function. Like so. If we call
baseball that describe, what do we get back?
You can see that baseball that describe returns a data frame in it of itself.
For every numerical column, we see the count, mean, standard deviation, mean,
25%, 50%, 75% and maximum
values. We can do some quick checking to make sure there are data generally
make sense. Here. LahmanID has actually been read in as a number, which is a bit
misleading. We won't be doing any arithmetic on
it. But we see that the minimum birth
month is one, and the maximum birth month is 12,
as we would expect. We see that the minimum birth date
is one, and the maximum birth date is 31. That
makes sense. And we see that the mean birth year is
actually 1928, which to me is surprising. I'd think that
it would be a little bit later. Investigating values like this,
we can tell pretty quickly what our data looks like,
and whether there might be any significant outliers in our data.
In other words, are the min or max way
larger than the values corresponding with the 25th or 75th
percentile. Although we won't discuss exploratory analysis of data
in depth, there's one thing that you might notice when
looking at a summary of your data. It may
have a bunch of missing values. This is evidenced here
by the differences in count for our various columns. Since
this is a particularly common problem. Let's discuss why values
may be missing. And different methods we can use to
mitigate the effect of those missing values on our analysis.